[Musique]
il a été l'un des premiers à populariser
un métier encore inconnu il y a 15 ans
youtubeur sa créativité lui a permis
d'engranger des millions de vues sans
oublier d'explorer la musique et le
cinéma et Sylvie ces expériences là en
solo il n'oublie pas les aventures
collectives comme celle de studio bagel
par exemple qui fête ses 10 ans avec une
fiction inédite diffusée vendredi soir à
22h40 sur Canal+ Mister V est en aparté
mais j'entends ok
c'est fou vous avez reproduit mon chez
moi ici
vous avez du goût alors le sas d'entrée
uniquement là c'est voilà c'est juste ma
pièce à vivre après il a encore 15 ans
alors vous faites exactement comme chez
vous personne n'a envie de ça comment
vous êtes à la maison en chaussettes en
jog comment quand je rentre déjà c'est
pas je peux peut-être pas dire de marque
mais moi c'est tout est connecté donc je
demande allume la lumière tout s'allume
enlève mes chaussures ça m'a un robot
qui vient de m'enlever directement mes
chaussures qui passent l'aspirateur sous
mes pieds ça va très vite ah ouais donc
vous êtes quand même attention souchieux
de votre intérieur il faut c'est
important
matériel pour qu'on soit soucieux soit
intérieur
de moi corporel et spirituel je
comprends bien à la maison vous êtes
plutôt canapé fauteuil ne bouge pas
c'est l'histoire de ma vie alors je vous
laisse tester dans cette société je
crois en parler un peu Nathalie
aujourd'hui ça fait du bien Aladdin vous
voulez tester le canapé il y a le
fauteuil il y a la chaise haute de bar
il y a le fauteuil voilà c'est à votre
guise je vais commencer là est-ce que ça
fait sortir mon bide là comme ça parce
que alors j'ai pris j'ai eu la très
mauvaise idée ce matin en préparant pour
venir ici de mettre un t-shirt un peu
moulant et disons que pendant les fêtes
il a un peu abusé
il y a une petite ceinture là je sais
pas si on la voit qui est pas très jolie
mais on va la travailler bientôt à la
salle Sofiane mon coach si tu me vois on
se voit tout à l'heure enfin je connais
un peu vos goûts en termes de
gastronomie et je suis pas étonné du
coup ceci explique cela
alors non mais ce qui est intéressant
parce que il faut quand même qu'on fasse
les choses un peu dans l'ordre
vous êtes vous créateur de contenu
YouTube chanteur premier pas d'acting
vous appelez Ivic ou Mister V c'est ça
sur la fiche d'identité c'est déjà ça
tout est correct tout est juste pour
l'instant ça indicieux indice au QCM non
mais vous savez que j'ai une question il
y a un verre là est-ce que je peux boire
ce qu'il y a dedans
c'est à se mettre une Suze ou une lève
dans la tête et la laisser là-bas ok
allez-y vous allez me dire je vois pas
de bulles ça m'a l'air très sobre oh
c'est du rhum
pure absolument
waouh mon préféré
comment il vous appelle vos potes
là-haut on s'appelle Ivic ou Mister V
moi je m'appelle Dwayne The Rock Johnson
parce que je ressemble un peu à The Rock
mais ça c'est vraiment que pour les
proches bon c'est évident parce que en
soit c'est déjà assez original c'est
assez drôle que j'ai choisi un pseudo
alors déjà mon prénom est porté par 38
personnes en France mais c'est 38
personnes en France depuis le début du
siècle enfin depuis 1900 pour être exact
bon bah alors à quand une cousinade avec
tous les livres de France parce que
c'est facile à retrouver j'essaie de
motiver tous mes potes qui dont la femme
va accoucher là pour que leur fille
s'appelle Ivic ou Ivic car si c'est une
fille personne est chaud alors je leur
dis mais je te sponsorise je te
sponsorise l'enfant 2500 par mois à vie
pourquoi tu veux appeler Timothée non
non
Mister V j'ai dû louper un épisode ou
une lettre de l'alphabet parce que
Mister V c'est pas Mister yah ah non
mais parce que Mister y
pas ouf non donc j'ai pris la lettre
d'après tout simplement l'histoire est
pas ouf parce que littéralement j'étais
sur Dailymotion donc le premier
hébergeur de vidéo sur lequel j'ai
commencé à poster et il fallait trouver
un pseudo et très vite vraiment j'avais
la pression de ah bah c'est maintenant
que tu que toute ma carrière le nom qui
va déterminer ma camion mais quand on
s'inscrit ça anecdotique quand on met
juste un login tu vois non utilisateur
et je voulais que ce soit un peu
différent de mon prénom que je fasse un
peu américain parce que évidemment je
suis très inspiré par l'Amérique et je
suis toujours et donc Mister était comme
une évidence et peut-être par référence
à Mr Bean sans le vouloir mais aussi
peut-être pas aussi
comment dire la non culture non plus
enfin peut-être que je connais pas tant
que c'est les USA j'ai dit tout de suite
mais c'est quoi le mot qui me dit
et j'ai pris Mister V il y a une
histoire qui dure aussi et d'ailleurs sa
date de 2012 au sein de studio bagel
collectif de youtubeurs créé par le
producteur Lorenzo mais des éthi qui
fête désormais
en fait en 2022 canal a relancé le
studio bagel ils avaient il s'était mis
sur pause pendant deux ans et vous
faites à nouveau partie de l'aventure
avec une série de sketchs intitulés
mst-ce que vous pouvez me faire la trade
déjà bien sûr c'est moyennement sur du
titre c'était littéralement les
initiales de les initiales qu'on a
choisi parce que on voulait un nom je
vous l'annonce un peu à la Men in Black
enfin vous savez ce genre de d'agence de
super-héros ou que ça fasse un peu voilà
un nom choc et comment être plus
choquant quand en évoquant des maladies
sexuellement transmissibles mais on
voulait voilà évidemment détourner le
nom et et voilà et puis c'est venu en
fait vraiment sur un coup de en impro on
était je me rappelle en tournage pour ma
vidéo des pizzas de la mama on était à
Nice et le nom m'est venu comme ça ça
aère tout le monde et on s'est dit
évidemment ça ne va pas passer on a
envoyé sa canal et c'est passé et je
sais pas comment donc
le directeur du studio vous êtes
doublement effectivement sur ce nom là
bagel c'est c'est quoi c'est un état
d'esprit c'est un collectif
de base simplement un sandwich rond avec
un trou au milieu ensuite
10 ans là je suis désolé mais il faut
que j'explique le terme en vrai comme il
est dans le dictionnaire non non en gros
c'est en fait un ouais voilà un
collectif de de créateur de contenu que
comme on l'appelle maintenant de
youtubeurs que que c'était rencontré
dans les années donc entre 2010 et 2012
et on faisait toujours des vidéos
ensemble mais on n'avait pas vraiment de
budget on est tous nos chaînes mais on
était tous à voilà un stade où quand on
voulait collaborer ensemble c'était
toujours bah assez amateur et donc Black
Dynamite à l'époque loazuma idetti
Vienne avec ce projet là et nous propose
de se lancer en en
et de proposer des sketchs toutes les
semaines dans un loft on écrit ensemble
et on poste des vidéos chaque semaine il
y avait pendant un moment on avait un
rythme de trois sketchs par semaine
c'était
c'était un rythme freiné ouais c'est ça
c'est frénétique il faut être hyper
créatif ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que on se nourrit de tout la rue
l'époque l'environnement les réseaux
vous savez après nous c'était un peu
naturel parce que déjà on commence à
faire des vidéos donc en soit tout ce
que on vivait tout ce qui se passait
tout était on notait tout ce qui se
passait dans la vraie vie le concept
même de vidéo Internet comment vous
allez à l'époque de podcast c'est
vachement de raconter la vidéo de ce qui
se passait autour de nous et bah en soi
c'était assez naturel que quand on avait
des réunions chacun avait amené des
idées et ont débattait et puis vu qu'on
était beaucoup ça allait beaucoup plus
vite on sélectionné les les les les
idées de chacun beaucoup plus vite et
même les nuits que vous avez passé
pendant un an et demi à dormir sur le
canapé de votre pote Jérôme
des contenus alors je les ai d'ailleurs
j'avais toujours dit qu'à l'époque
j'allais le payer un jour pour le
remercier tout ça j'ai pas encore fait
donc Jérôme tu regardes ça t'inquiète
pas
envoie-moi ton mail Paypal je règle ça
tout de suite aujourd'hui disons après
non je dormais pendant un an et demi sur
son sur son canapé il habite donc en
colocation avec Axel malevernet qui avec
qui travaille aujourd'hui avec qui il a
une boîte de production et qui est aussi
ont bossé justement sur les 10 ans du
bagel et
et ouais bah c'était heureusement que je
remercierai jamais assez Jérôme parce
que c'était vraiment une période en plus
qui était
comment dire
comment on dit une période très
importante charnière let's go c'était le
mot que je cherchais charnière parce que
c'est pile quand je commence des études
que mes parents donc
hésite à me laisser partir à Paris mais
quand même veulent que j'aille au bout
de mes études je faisais un DUT
Information communication qui a duré
cinq mois puisque je me suis fait virer
du contrôle continu parce que j'avais
une arme c'est faux j'étais jamais là
parce que j'allais tout le temps à Paris
faire des vidéos avec les gars justement
et Paris voilà Grenoble Paris et
et je rencontre mon agent avec qui je
suis que j'embrasse avec qui je suis
depuis 12 ans maintenant Alexandra
Monory et elle conva mes parents de me
laisser partir et donc quand je vais à
Paris il me faut bien un toit j'ai pas
un budget illimité j'ai même pas de
budget du tout donc
Jérôme me prête très gentiment ça
m'inquiète
alors ce qui nous amène cette
construction et cette prise de poids au
sens figuré
pour cette soirée spéciale ce sera
vendredi soir à 22h40 sur Canal+ voilà
où canapé vous a conduit disponible
aussi sur mycanal cette soirée on va
regarder un extrait de ce que ça va
donner
il se transforme en or est-ce que le
studio bagel vous a permis d'accomplir
des choses que vous n'auriez jamais
imaginé
donc ça va
vous a permis d'accomplir des choses
auxquelles vous n'auriez jamais pensé
et voilà cet anniversaire avec cette
fiction 60 minutes écrite par Axel
maliverner Arthur pilou Perrier Clément
Beyrouth animé par Pauline Clément on
l'a reconnu Bertrand escla Audrey
Pierrot bah voilà Mister V devenu une
égérie de nombreux produits plus balafui
un vrai homme sandwich ça vous a
évidemment éclaté ouais et puis et puis
évidemment c'était rigolo de
voilà de de détourner ça de parodier ça
parce que c'est vrai on peut le dire je
suis parti d'un studio qui a un nom de
sandwich pour devenir un homme sandwich
est-ce que finalement tout n'était pas
allé tout n'était pas écrit 10 ans à
l'avance et ça c'est fou de moi en
couple maintenant waouh et ça donne une
chaîne qui cumule 3 millions et demi
d'abonnés sur Youtube on attend de
nouveaux programmes comme les frères
Pétou avec Monsieur Poulpe la saison 2
d'Antoine avec Yann kojandi ses invités
gradins moitié également vous avez des
des projets vous dans les cartons comme
ça nous dévoiler maintenant qu'on se
connait mieux pour ma pour ma chaîne
youtube
il y a des vidéos qui sont en
préparation mais en dehors de youtube il
y a un projet de long métrage qui est
dans les qui est dans les tuyaux mais on
a encore dans à l'état d'écriture là
j'ai envie d'avoir mon projet à moi donc
c'est ça le la prochaine étape et je
fais également en train de préparer mon
troisième album
de rap et vous chômez pas donc il faut
prendre des forces donc je vous invite
au comptoir regardez il y a de quoi
boire aussi un petit élixir qui va bien
je vois un jus ouais
je vous laisse goûter alors ça c'est
typiquement un truc de bobo qui fait du
yoga mais vous en faites pas la maison
comme banane kiwi épinards
j'ai appuyé pas du tout appuyé ils sont
une dizaine à vivre une belle histoire
grâce à leur vidéo
le seul souci c'est que je sais pas ce
que je veux faire après le plus jeune de
la bande c'est lui à 18 ans Mister V a
déjà un agent de nombreux rendez-vous
ces clips vidéos sont devenus un
business vous envoyez tout ça au client
et vous me dites après ce qu'il faut que
je modifie et voilà il doit vendre
quatre vidéos à une entreprise qui
cherche à améliorer son image auprès des
jeunes
vous avez juste 18 ans c'est en 2012
reportage du 20h de TF1 qui suit votre
quotidien de youtubeur vous êtes vous
êtes un ovni à l'époque en quelque sorte
aussi le sujet quoi c'est vraiment on
parle de la découverte à ce moment-là
ils sont dans la découverte sur les
chaînes historiques
quoi qui qui vend des blagues à des
entreprises quoi il y avait de ça
évidemment mais c'est marrant parce que
à l'époque c'était tellement nouveau
qu'on comment dire on traitait que de ce
que cette partie là mais c'est drôle
parce que je vois Alexandra mon agent
dont je parlais avant et donc ça c'était
2012 donc c'est à 11 ans et déjà à
l'époque bah on
travaille on se fait assez beau quoi
l'évolution est belle ça fait plaisir
vous faisiez des style a bien évolué je
suis content aujourd'hui vous avez 30
ans là effectivement vous en avez 18
vous faisiez des vidéos de basket avant
au niveau du poids c'était bien là
j'avais la bonne chape il faut que je
retourne à ça je m'égare non mais c'est
vous qui appuyez là où ça fait mal hein
moi j'ai rien dit à l'époque vous
faisiez des des vidéos de basket enfin
même bien en amont hein vous souvenez la
première vidéo humoristique qui publiait
sur votre chaîne Youtube et qui prend la
première caprice c'était au moins
podcast qui était une vidéo je parlais
de mes problèmes de maths
moi à l'époque je suis au lycée c'est
pas du tout de coutume de que de faire
des vidéos dans sa chambre de pas la sa
caméra de mettre ça en ligne c'est un
peu s'afficher en fait donc les les gens
de autour de moi sont pas
obligatoirement ouverts à collaborer
avec moi donc carrément à l'époque je me
duplique de mes vidéos je me dédouble je
joue les tous les rôles parce que j'ose
pas demander à mes potes parce que je
sais que ça peut les ça peut les gêner
ou même j'en parle pas autour de moi
donc la débrouille elle est encore pire
dans le sens où carrément je dois me
filmer tout seul je dois changer de
tenue faire mon mon double donc il y a
en plus de ça ouais une petite solitude
où on se dit bon bah est-ce que
qu'est-ce que ça va où est-ce que je
vais aller avec ça mais il y a pas de
projet d'aller vraiment quelque part
mais du coup bah tous les moyens sont
bons pour pour essayer de développer une
idée avec les moyens du bord ouais donc
des fois ça va créer alors papa et maman
n'ont rien à voir avec le milieu
artistique on est d'accord pour autant
il vous offre un caméscope votre papa
assez tôt dès l'âge de 7 ans vous filmez
avec
je pense que c'est lui qui m'a donné le
goût à l'humour comme j'aime dire ma
mère aussi mais elle m'a fait exprès
parce qu'elle est drôle sur le vouloir
et mon frère aussi mon grand frère aussi
à une grosse
inspiré une grosse rentabilité de dans
mes goûts pour l'Amérique dans mon kiffe
pour la musique pour le rap celui qui
m'a mis très vite très tôt à la musique
pour autant il aimait pas trop que j'en
fasse ça c'est drôle maintenant parce
que l'écoute il écoute beaucoup mes sons
et il est suit beaucoup et notamment sa
fille aimée que j'embrasse qui écoute
aussi beaucoup mes sons alors on
enchaîne une image let's go attendez
j'appuie sur le bouton
l'épreuve approche et les équipes
reçoivent un indice très complexe pour
anticiper cette échéance cruciale tu as
dit quoi alerte vous devrez tirer une
bouée extrêmement lourde jusqu'à un
ponton flottant
je suis pas votre but
William c'est mon préféré le mec qui est
malade il a pas de limite il va
s'arrêter psychopathe tu as un exprès la
limite elle est suivie
polaire le mec comme Kanye West
le flambeau série Jonathan Cohen
toujours dispo sur mycanal vous jouez un
rôle qui mettait en abyme votre votre
job votre profession youtubeur vous êtes
William celui qui veut faire le buzz là
on touche du doigt une sorte de rêve ou
pas surtout que moi en tant que grand
fan de la flamme c'était un petit rêve
ouais un honneur d'être appelé par
Jonathan et Jérémy galant je trouve que
c'est l'un des plus grands acteurs de
comédie de sa génération c'est un
bonheur de bosser avec lui mis à part
les problèmes d'haleine
qui a dit ça Jonathan alors votre droit
de réponse c'est maintenant
il a dit ça bah oui mais c'était vous
saviez pas c'est pas arrivé
[Rires]
pas ça bah déjà j'aimerais lui envoyer
le compliment sur le côté acteur de des
meilleurs acteurs de sa génération pour
moi c'est je pense à l'heure actuelle
l'homme le plus le plus marrant et le
plus complet en termes de de comédie et
même la façon et sa direction d'acteur
elle est folle ça on le voit pas quand
on regarde quand on le voit parce qu'on
voit que lui en train de jouer et la
série en soi mais il a porté énormément
en plus de de la simple comédie la porte
énormément en direction il s'est très
bien gérer ses acteurs et faire en sorte
que tout match ensemble et que chacun et
sa place sans que comment dire c'est une
équipe quoi il arrive à la faire vivre
ensemble et ça c'est un vrai talent je
trouve c'est pas tout le monde qui sait
faire ça on va regarder une autre image
[Musique]
pourquoi je rêve je veux faire le tour
de la terre donc je coupe mon terre
chaque jour toute la semaine double
[Musique]
à faire moi ne faut pas que je me perde
là
je sais pas si je mérite l'attention
qu'on m'apporte faut pas croire que la
chose je m'attendra devant la porte il y
a des imprévus mais malgré tout je suis
pas tes mains qui fait tout pour rester
dans la main
c'est très métal comme situation parce
que je regarde un clip dans lequel
je me regarde aussi plus petit et je
regarde des moments de moi avant
mon guide préféré déjà d'une parce que
je l'ai monté et c'est fou à quel point
j'avais énormément d'image de moi petit
que mon père avait gardé que mes parents
de garder et c'est aussi dans ces
moments là qu'on se rend compte de de je
vais aller loin mais de tout l'amour en
fait que que nos parents ou que la
famille peut porter pour moi et ce
depuis très petit donc c'est très très
fort et très très prenant que de monter
ce clip parce que vraiment je suis allé
dans un j'ai revu toute ma vie quoi et
de le faire au final et de ce qui
raconte et ce qui symbolise pour moi et
c'est un des maisons préférés parce que
il est je suis vraiment un nu dans le
sous c'est vraiment moi à 100% alors
parce qu'on est sur la famille et cette
transmission qui est importante je crois
pour vous il y a une femme qui s'appelle
Georgette votre grand-mère dont vous
êtes très proche
elle vous a inspiré comment elle a
est-ce qu'elle a compris ce que vous
faisiez aujourd'hui
les créations de contenu je sais pas
c'est il y a quand même évidemment un
saut de génération elle a compris mais
elle est quand même en dehors en dehors
de tout ça et c'est mieux comme ça c'est
ce que j'ai essayé de ce dont j'ai
besoin aussi c'est d'avoir quelqu'un qui
a
pas la même vie qui a pas les mêmes
codes mais qui a les pieds tellement
ancré dans le sol et qui est tellement
qui est tellement bon qui est tellement
pure
j'ai vraiment besoin de de ça et
c'est pour ça que je vais souvent la
voir qu'on s'appelle presque tous les
jours et quand j'ai cette ce rapport là
et c'est ce qui a fait que le son
FaceTime aussi a plu aux gens c'est un
son sur ma grand-mère qui est dans mon
deuxième album et je pense que c'est ça
qui a fait parce que notre l'amour qu'on
a pour l'un pour l'autre et la notre
relation elle est elle est rare je pense
et j'ai de la chance de l'avoir encore
aujourd'hui parce que c'est comme c'est
comme ma mère elle a on a grandi dans la
même dans la même maison elle vivait
avec nous
donc elle m'a le fait qu'elle soit en
dehors tu sais qu'elle connaisse pas
trop c'est c'est vraiment important pour
moi
un mot encore parce que évidemment on a
joué cette cette extrême là aujourd'hui
votre tout dernier single qui sortit en
février
match c'est ça dites-moi deux albums de
disques de platine quand on arrive dans
le rap alors que on a frayé avec
l'humour et que on s'est fait une vraie
place dans l'humour
comment comment on imagine être
accueilli dans le rap et comment vous
l'avez été
on n'imagine pas du tout être bien
accueilli ou du moins on pense pas que
ça puisse être
si on s'imagine que ça va être compliqué
mais ce premier album ça a été ça a été
quand même une sacrée étape mentale dans
le sens où jusqu'à présent j'avais
toujours eu des dans tout ce que je
faisais donc notamment de l'humour enfin
principalement de l'humour des retours
toujours bienveillants et plutôt bon et
quand on rentre dans la musique et qu'on
vient pas de ce monde-là et évidemment
des gens que ça dérange et évidemment
des gens que ça peut faire un marais qui
comprennent pas qui ne qui n'arrivent
pas à rentrer dans le délire donc des
fois des retours un peu qui peuvent être
un peu dur mais il fallait y passer
j'avais pas de modèle non plus moi dans
mon dans mon game de gens qui parlent
passé avait fait de l'humour et venez de
l'humour il avait fait du rap premier
degré parce que c'est ça surtout c'est
pas un album parodique donc on laisse
pas vraiment le choix aux gens c'est
vraiment là je me mets à nu et sous la
musique c'est encore différent de
l'humour c'est que vraiment on est
sincère on essaie d'être le plus sincère
et on s'ouvre un peu on se met un peu à
poil quand même devant les gens donc
dès que tu vois un commentaire et que
c'est écrit que tout l'album il est
éclaté au sol et ben ça fait un peu mal
mais
je suis très très fier d'avoir accompli
ça et en réalité il y a eu beaucoup plus
de positif que de négatif vous voulez
bien
la bibliothèque bien sûr là j'étais bien
posé
ok
alors après la cheminée vous avez un
rayon une étagère DVD une étagère
musique et une étagère livre ok c'est
trop bien je reconnais un peu il y a
toutes mes inspire
mais alors j'ai plusieurs questions
rapides d'abord est-ce que vous pouvez
vous effeuiller en public
je traduis non mais vous avez des
tatouages waouh ok oui j'en ai 9
ok tatouage comme ça au moins c'est là
je sais pas si je peux ouvrir ma chemise
parce que le micro est accroché là c'est
toujours tatouage
bah ouais à chaque fois j'arrive et il
me dit tu veux quoi je fais ah j'ai
oublié bon on va faire le même moment
comme ça on est sûr de rester c'est
toujours
être
nu en fait ce sera votre habit bah ça
serait ce serait fou tu vois à la fin de
ma vie une œuvre une œuvre en tant que
tel maintenant pour l'instant je garde
ça et parce que j'ai pas d'idée non plus
en vrai j'ai pas d'idée littéralement
vous avez encore le temps de changer
d'avis 10 fois de toute façon et puis
après je peux aussi faire des des
variantes je peux mettre tatouage en
russe en chinois en anglais je peux
vraiment varier
au chapitre musique typiquement j'avais
envie de partager un truc avec vous
parce que c'est vraiment je crois de
notre point commun fondateur
[Musique]
chinois dans le bleu des photos dans le
regard d'un chat dans les soldats oiseau
dans la force d'un arbre dans la couleur
de l'eau je te survivrai
dans l'hiver et le vent dans le froid
des maisons
voilà c'est exactement ce que j'espère
[Musique]
ah non arrêtez pas arrêtez pas j'ai
envie de danser encore
ça ressemble à du break des années 80
mais vous étiez pas né ça colle pas non
bon alors c'est quand même Jean-Pierre
François c'est un classique et je pense
que c'est l'inspiration principale de
pourquoi j'ai fait du rap c'est
quelqu'un qui vient du football qui
s'est lancé dans la musique car je pense
su ainsi au moins un disque d'or je
pense que ça a bien marché à l'époque
donc on peut le dire c'est un peu mon
père spirituel
la fascination pour cette double
carrière qu'il a menait qu'il a mené et
c'est ça tout est là j'ai deux idoles
c'est lui et Michael Jordan
du côté de Malibu la baie vitrée
ah trop bien c'est le alors c'est pas
l'appareil non
ok
ça m'a l'air un peu je peux l'ouvrir
mais bien sûr je vous en prie on va en
profiter
je le dois
c'est pas des manières
bon merci merci
que j'aime beaucoup
tellement j'aime beaucoup que je l'ai
déjà bah voilà mais c'est l'intention
qui compte merci beaucoup Nathalie au
moins vous êtes incollable pour de bons
mais après je vais le mettre dans ma
déco chez moi je peux
il est déjà la mince je sais que je peux
le mettre alors que ça fasse pas bon je
vais le mettre là c'est toujours
Chicot pour autant vous voulez bien le
tester ou pas bien sûr alors en mode
autoportrait avec une petite pastille
orange face sur la face de l'appareil
une première fois pour allumer et au
niveau du décor on s'en fout je me vais
où je vais là où ça vous dit ok
je vais me mettre devant
devant ma libout
re elle sait pas ouvrir les yeux sur les
photos je tiens ça d'elle
non là c'est bon
vous vous pouvez quand même embarquer
notre cadeau ça nous ferait plaisir
merci merci d'être à vous d'être passé
par là
de m'avoir initié à plein de choses et
il était spectateurs aussi je pense
salut Mister V merci beaucoup vu que
c'est chez moi oui bah voyons allez on
vous retrouve en tout cas dans la
fiction inédit diffusée vendredi soir à
22h40 sur Canal+ ciné studio bagel pour
ses 10 ans rendez-vous pris et vous
revenez quand vous voulez bah vous avez
vraiment un premier temps
c'est bon
salut demain demain
[Musique]
te tue je
préfère comme un revenant je te fuis
[Musique]